So welcome to week
three of AA203.
So as per our usual road
map, today, we are-- today
and tomorrow will be still
in the open-loop quadrant
of our road map.
Specifically last week, so we
introduced the general concept
of open-loop control,
which is to be compared
to with closed-loop
control, which
will be the topic of next week.
And specifically, in
open-loop control,
we highlighted the
fact that we are
interested in control,
an optimal control
signal or trajectory,
which is only
a signal of the initial time t.
So we are looking for an optimal
control trajectory, u of t.
And specifically, within
this class of methods,
we discussed that there are
two macro subcategories,
indirect methods
and direct methods.
Last week, we introduced
indirect methods
which, loosely speaking,
relate with, first of all,
deriving optimality conditions
for the infinite dimensional
optimal control problem
and solving for those.
If you wish, the analog
we usually recalled
was the one from finite
dimensional optimization,
whereby the
optimality conditions
were akin to the gradient
of f equal to 0 conditions.
Of course, in finite
dimensional case,
those kind of
optimality conditions,
so gradient equal
to 0, boil down
to a system of
algebraic equations.
In the case of infinite
dimensional optimization, which
is the one you're interested
in for optimal control--
these optimality condition boils
down to differential equations,
but the high level
picture is the same.
And so today, we will be
finishing our discussion
on indirect methods.
And then on Wednesday, we'll
be looking at direct methods.
And specifically
for today, we will
start by extending the
optimality conditions which
we introduced last
time, which assumed
that we had unbounded controls.
And so today, we
will be extending
those optimality
conditions specifically
for the case of
bounded controls, which
is a very common constraint
to have in practice
when you're dealing with
optimal control problems.
And we will see how this will
lead towards the celebrated
Pontryagin's minimum principle.
We'll then look at various
different examples.
Specifically,
we'll be looking at
some archetype optimal control
problems, first of all,
to see how we can use
these optimality conditions
in practice and get
familiarity with that but also
from the perspective of
inspecting the kind of control
profile that we get out of
these optimality conditions.
And then we'll
conclude this part
by looking at
computational methods.
So we have been describing
indirect methods over and over
as optimized then discretized
methods, again, in comparison
to the direct approaches
which are discretized then
optimized methods,
and specifically
the optimized part
entailed with deriving
the optimality conditions and
solving for those differential
equations, and the
discretized part related
with feeding those
differential equations
to a numerical
solver, which is also
what we'll be looking at with
the computational methods.
So just as a
reminder, so last time
we concluded by looking
at this optimal control
problem where we had assumed
that we had unbounded controls.
So, again, to recap
the notation here,
we assume that we have a system
described by the following
dynamics.
And the goal is to find an
admissible control u star, which
causes the system to follow
an admissible trajectory, x
star, that minimizes the
given cost functional,
which is a combination
of a terminal cost h
and a state cost g that
is integrated over time.
And indeed, we assumed that
both the states and the control
regions were unbounded.
And this led into defining the
following optimal necessary
optimality conditions, which
at a high level, entailed,
first of all, defining the
Hamiltonian, which is you want
acted as the analog of
the Lagrangian function
in finite dimensional
case, where
we basically-- where the
Hamiltonian is defined
as the state cost plus a term
which represents our dynamic f
times a vector of cost--
or a function of costates p
of t, which again represents
the analog of the Lagrangian
multipliers.
And infinite dimensional
optimization--
the Lagrange multipliers
were denoted as lambda.
Here, we denote these
costates as p, which
are indeed a function of time.
And they're called
costates because there
is one costate variable or
function for every state
function.
And so given that we
define this Hamiltonian,
we saw how the optimality
conditions boil down
to defining the
set of differential
equations, the first one
representing trivially
our dynamics.
So if we take the partial
derivative of our Hamiltonian
with respect to the costate
variable p, we get our dynamics,
so x dot equals f.
The second two set of
equations are less intuitive,
but we saw how the second one
essentially boiled down to p
dot equals the--
minus the partial derivative
of the Hamiltonian
with respect to x.
And then we saw how the third
set of algebraic equations
represented a stationary
condition of the control
with respect to the Hamiltonian.
And so essentially,
that the derivative
of the Hamiltonian with respect
to u needs to be equal to 0.
And we saw how in practice this
boiled down very mechanically
towards usually using this
last set of algebraic equations
to express u as a
function of x and p.
We can then do the
appropriate substitutions
in the differential equations,
which we can then solve.
To solve these
differential equations,
we saw how this generated
a-- it boiled down
into having to pinpoint a number
of constants of integration.
And we saw how we could use
boundary conditions to pinpoint
those constants of integration.
Usually, the initial boundary
conditions are given.
So we know the state at time 0,
and we know what the time 0 is.
But the boundary conditions
at the final time
depend a bit on the scenario
that we're looking at.
And so we saw how we could use
this master boundary condition,
depending on whether the
final time or final state
is free or fixed.
For example, if the
final state is fixed,
it means that there are
no admissible variations.
Delta xf we can do.
And so all of this
term has to go to 0.
And so we're left with this
other part of the boundary
condition and vice versa.
Any questions on-- until this as
a general recap of where we are?
And indeed-- so as I
mentioned before, so far,
we have assumed that both
the admissible controls
and state are not constrained
by any boundaries.
But in reality, states
and control constraints
are actually extremely
common in practice.
So, for example, a classical
control constraints
might model that we have
some limits in our actuation.
So again, we cannot impose a
thrust that is infinitely large.
And also, state constraints
might be quite common.
For example, just
to give you an idea,
a classical state
constraint might
represent obstacle
avoidance, so where
we want to avoid some obstacle
in the physical space.
Now, for the purpose
of this class,
we'll focus on including the
case of bounds on the controls.
And we will not
discuss the case where
we include the bounds or
constraints on the states, first
of all, because the mechanics
become substantially
more and more complex and
also because, in practice,
indirect methods are not
really the tool of choice
to handle constraints on states.
So what people
usually do with maybe
cast the problem as a
motion planning problem--
we're abstracting away from
the dynamics, or at least
simplifying the dynamics,
and more geometrically
solving the trajectory
optimization problem.
And then you're
using those insights
that you get from these
more abstract solutions
to inform your indirect methods.
So long story short, but
what we're saying here
is that we want to
expand our analysis,
and we're going to focus on
the bounds on the controls.
Yes.
[INAUDIBLE] last lecture where
we were using the conditions
for optimal control, the one
you have in the previous slide.
And then we had a t final equals
some expression in terms of a.
You were saying that your--
was that actually-- when
we solved that problem,
did we actually find that
optimal control for-- this
is what you're saying that
you could be anything.
Therefore, tf could be anything.
And now we're going
to introduce--
What setting are
you referring to?
In previous lecture, we did
an example of the t final
in terms of alpha--
Yes.
Did that correspond to some
particular optimal control?
Or is that what you're saying,
that it was unconstrained
so the control
could be anything,
and therefore, the t
final could be anything?
No.
So in that case, we actually
solved the problem completely.
So in this slide, I only
highlighted the final time tf,
which was a complex thing.
It's over 1,800 or
something like that.
But, of course, once we solve
for the necessary optimality
conditions, so once we solve
the differential equations,
we have everything.
So we have x.
We have p.
And usually, the controls
are a function of x and p.
And so by just substituting
those x and p that we
get by solving the
differential equations,
we would get the
shape of our control.
So here, what I mean
by bounds on controls
is that we would have something
like the absolute value of u
needs to be smaller or equal
than 1, something like that.
Does this clarify?
Is it possible that
because we didn't
have the constraint
in the other problem
that for some given
alpha and b, it
could result in the
optimal control that
violates a constraint?
Yes, of course.
And we were not imposing
this constraint.
So we are not really
sure about if we're
respecting any kind of
constraint like this.
Yeah.
But it will be clear
in a couple of slides
because we'll be making
some concrete examples.
So now, before showing you how
the optimality conditions will
change, I just want to
give you a small insight
into why the bounds
on the controls
complicate the analysis.
And the way we'll build this
intuition is by, as usual,
referring to the finite
dimensional case.
And so recall from
our discussions
on finite dimensional
optimization
where in order to derive
the optimality conditions
of the gradient of f
needs to be equal to 0,
we started by looking
at the increment
of our function with respect
to some displacement delta x.
And we saw how this could
be well approximated
by our function f of x plus the
gradient of f transpose delta x,
or we call this the differential
plus some higher order terms.
And essentially, by
just bringing the f
of x on the other side
of the equation, what
we get is that the
increment of our function
is well approximated for a small
delta x's by our differential,
so the linear part of our
approximation-- of our Taylor
expansion.
And we know that for a point x
to be a candidate local minimum,
what it means is that for
any displacement delta
x that I make,
this increment has
to be greater or equal than 0.
So wherever I move,
essentially, I'm
increasing the value
of my function.
Now, in the
unconstrained case, we
were able to translate this
expansion so that-- specifically
that the differential has to
be greater or equal than 0
to the fact that in order
for this to be greater
or equal than 0, since I can
take any possible displacement
delta x both in the positive
and in the negative direction,
the only way for this to be
both greater than, equal than 0
or less than or equal than
0 is for the gradient of f
to be equal to 0.
So this is essentially what we
said a couple of weeks back.
Now, visually,
what this means is
that if we have a function
that looks something like this,
and assuming I'm not
considering the boundary
points of this function,
the gradient of f equal to 0
essentially gives us a
mechanism to isolate candidates
for local minimums, where
specifically, in this case,
one is a local minimum and
two here are local maximum.
But still, they're
candidates according
to our optimality conditions.
Now, what happens if we do
consider the boundaries here?
So is this a local minima?
I see some nodding.
Can you say why this
is a local minima?
Yes.
Because if you move
anywhere on that curve,
that's still within
your boundaries.
And they're always--
Exactly correct.
So in this case, remember that
here, we're defining minimums
as whatever movement
admissible delta x I take,
I'm increasing the
value of my function.
In this case, the only
displacements I can take
are ones on the positive
direction on the right.
And so for all of these
displacements, the value
my function is greater.
So this is indeed
a local minimum.
Same thing for this other
point here, of course,
mirrored where the only
displacements that I can take
are in the negative direction.
So you see that when I'm
considering these boundaries,
the condition that the
gradient of f is equal to 0
doesn't really cut it anymore.
And so going back to this math,
what we know in the bounded case
is that this has to hold.
But we're not able to do the
point that these displacements
can be both in the positive
or negative direction,
but they depend on the boundary.
And so the optimality
condition in this case
is that the differential has
to be greater or equal than 0.
Now, this complicates a
series of other discussions
when we actually want
to make this actionable.
But this is the
difference that it makes
in the finite dimensional case.
In the infinite
dimensional case,
when we move to optimizing
to calculus of variation,
the exact same
intuition applies.
And specifically,
remember that we
derived the optimality
conditions, again,
starting from the variation of
our cost functional j, which
we denoted as delta j.
And in order for
a candidate, you
start to be a minimum
or a relative minimum.
We wanted this increment
is greater than 0,
so exactly as in the
finite dimensional case.
Now, what we did last week
is that we approximated
this increment through its
linear term or the variation
delta j plus some
higher order terms.
And then we use the
fact that these delta
u's could be arbitrary to
derive the fundamental theorem
of calculus of variation.
That is the delta j, so
the variation delta j
needed to be equal to 0.
So I trust that you're
seeing the analog here.
Now, when we talk about--
let's open a small parenthesis.
When we talk about variations
in calculus of variation, so
what does delta u look like?
Because a displacement in delta
x intuitively makes sense.
But here, we're talking
about functions.
So delta u itself is a function.
So if you want visually say that
we have a function over time
and that we have some
bound in our controls,
which we denote as u bar,
meaning that our controls cannot
go above this bound, our control
u of t might look something like
this, where for some time we
are in the admissible region.
Then we are still admissible
but at the boundary.
And then perhaps
we could go down.
So this could be a potential
control function ut.
So a displacement
delta ut in this case
is a function in itself.
So it could be any variation
that I do to my function ut.
Now, in this part of the region
where I'm not at the boundary,
the variations that I can take
could be both delta u but also
negative delta u.
So variations is both
directions are admissible.
But in the case where my control
lies at the boundary, then here,
I can only take the variation
in only on one-sided,
if that makes sense.
And so what this boils
down to-- and in general,
whenever I'm trying
to optimize some--
could be final time
given some constraints,
it is very common that u--
for some portion of my control
profile, I will be at the
boundary at some point.
And it turns out that if
the optimal control lies
on a boundary, then the
necessary conditions, similarly
to how it did in the finite
dimensional case, essentially
boils down that the
variation delta j has
to be greater or equal than 0.
Any questions on how we got to
this update to our conditions?
Yes.
Sorry if you mentioned it
before, but on that lower plot
that you have there,
what was the connection
to that expression to
the-- you could only
vary in one direction point?
Sorry.
Can you repeat the question?
So here?
Yeah, I think I'm confused how
that would be a situation where
you could only--
I think you said something
like vary in one direction.
Yes.
No, it's a good question.
So remember that a lot of the
logic that we're following when
we're doing those
statements over there
was that the admissible
variations were arbitrary.
And so this allowed us
to essentially derive
that the variation of j-- so
delta j has to be equal to 0
in the fundamental theorem
of calculus of variation.
So here, I was
trying to visualize
what does it mean
for, first of all,
to be a variation in the
space of functions, but then
also, what does it mean for
a variation to be bounded
so that it's not arbitrary.
So in this space of my
control function, here,
my variations are
actually arbitrary.
So admissible variations
are arbitrary because I
could go in both directions.
Here, when my control
is at a boundary,
I cannot displace my function in
the positive direction because I
would violate my bounds.
Yeah.
And so the only thing
that I meant here
is that the boundaries
essentially break the assumption
that my variations are--
that any variation
is admissible.
And so this does not allow
us to make the statement
that the delta j is equal to 0.
Yeah.
Now, this-- of
course, then you can
imagine that the
consequences of this
on our optimality conditions
are that we have to strengthen
our condition on the control u.
And specifically, these
are the updated conditions,
which are referred to as the
Pontryagin's minimum principle,
where we are--
as it is I highlighted
here on the slide,
we're essentially
updating and strengthening
the condition on the
stationarity of our control u.
So everything stays exactly
the same as the conditions
that we saw before, with the
addition that-- or modification
that before.
The optimal control u had
to be a stationary point
of the Hamiltonian.
So the gradient of
h with respect to u
had to be equal to 0.
Now we want the
optimal control u
to be a global minimizer
of the Hamiltonian.
So essentially, the
Hamiltonian evaluated
at the optimal
candidate u star is
a smaller or equal than
the Hamiltonian evaluated
at any other u of t,
admissible control u.
Of course, there is
a jump from the fact
that the variation
has to be greater
or equal than 0 towards the
updated optimality conditions.
But the bottom line
here is, again, we
want to be pragmatic
and functional.
And when we introduce
bounds on our controls,
it boils down towards
updating and strengthening
some of our optimality
conditions, which in this case
entails having to minimize the
Hamiltonian rather than only
being a stationary point.
Any questions here?
Again, mechanically, we
provided some insight
into what is more
complex the moment
we consider bounds on controls.
And then we stated the
updated optimality conditions.
So let's now make an example
to operationalize these updated
optimality conditions.
And so specifically here, we are
looking at the following system,
which is a second-order
system with linear dynamics
and where we want to
optimize the cost functional
that is represented as a squared
cost function or quadratic cost
functional.
We are assuming that
the final time is fixed
and the final stage is free.
But note that here,
now we are introducing
this bound on the
controls, specifically
that the absolute value has to
be less than or equal than 1.
When we are-- so these
type of problems,
that is, when we are
trying to minimize
the squared of our controls,
so our quadratic cost are also
known as minimum
energy problems.
Yes.
I have a question
about the definition
from the previous slide.
What does it mean
to say that you're--
you know that inequality of
h of all the stuff stars--
Yeah, yeah.
What does it mean for
u not to be optimal,
but x and p's will be--
how can you have a non-optimal
u of the optimal examples?
So in general,
remember that these
are a set of conditions for any
candidate triplet of states,
controls, and costates.
Now, the first two are
differential equations.
Here, we are basically
strengthening
the algebraic conditions,
which essentially
entail that the controls,
the candidate control u,
have to be a stationary point
for the Hamiltonian given
x and p.
And in this, we
basically strengthening
that condition, whereby
you should basically
see that we are trying
to minimize this function
only as a function of u.
So given some x and p's, we
are finding the global minimum
with respect to u of h.
OK.
But [INAUDIBLE] just given
some u as [INAUDIBLE].
If you want there,
you could also
interpret it as u star
needs to be the arg
min of h of x star u t star.
So this is basically saying
that for any candidate u star t,
it has to be a global
minimizer for any other u of t
that I could replace it with.
I remember we're
now highlighting
that this is a global minimum.
Was it not the global
minimum before?
Before, we only
needed that u had
to be a stationary point
of the Hamiltonian.
We only enforced
that the derivative,
the partial derivative of the
Hamiltonian with respect to u
had to be equal to 0.
Now, we're actually
enforcing that
for the strengthened
condition. u not only
has to be a stationary
point, but it
has to be a global minimum.
So I know that we
took a big jump
in defining this strengthened
condition, but maybe
one way in which
you could relate
this condition to the one
we had previously, that is,
how to relate the global
minimization of the Hamiltonian
with respect to u and the
stationary point condition,
is that--
so this condition is essentially
strengthened because we are
introducing bounds on controls.
Now, assume that we are
loosening these bounds
on the controls so much.
So visually, if
you remember here,
we had this u bar which
represented our bound.
We are increasing it so much
that is not an issue anymore
for our problem.
If we are increasing it
so much that it's not
any more an issue
for our problem,
then any global minimum
of our Hamiltonian
is also a stationary point.
So there is a link
here in the sense
that if our control bounds
are so loose that they're not
an issue anymore, then a
necessary condition for control
u to be a global minimum of h
is it to be a stationary point.
How do you see here [INAUDIBLE]?
No, this is just
a mental exercise,
just to show some link between
this formulation and the one
we had previously.
Did this confuse you even more?
Oh, yeah.
Bottom line here is
that we want to define
these optimality conditions.
Now, we are-- compared to the
one where we had previously,
we are introducing some
bound on the controls.
This bound of the
controls boils down
to having to strengthen this
third algebraic condition.
Before, it was just
enforcing that u
had to be a stationary
point of the Hamiltonian.
Now, we want u's to be a global
minimizer of the Hamiltonian.
Yes.
[INAUDIBLE] control
inputs, we would--
if my other condition would
use to find the optimal control
inputs and then plug those
into the differential
equations for x and p.
But I'm having
trouble understanding
how we would optimize over--
we would optimize
over the Hamiltonian
as if we already knew the
optimal state and x star and t
star, because I assume
that the x and the control
inputs in the
states are a couple.
Yeah, it's a great question.
And it will be clear I
think one slide for now
because we're exactly
solving a problem,
and so you'll see how we do it.
The bottom line is
that obviously, this
is complicating things because
before, it was just enforcing
an algebraic equation
where we would express
x as a functional-- u
as a function of x and p
and then doing the substitution.
Now, we will be solving this--
we will basically have to
solve an optimization problem
and derive a solution of
u as a function of x and p
and then doing the
substitution again.
So mechanically, it
doesn't change much.
It's just more complex
because before, it
was enforcing an
algebraic equation.
Now, it's solving an
optimization problem.
Yeah.
So indeed, we want to approach
this minimum energy problem
where now we have some
bounds on the controls.
And specifically, again,
we want to be-- as usual,
we want to be methodical.
So we define the Hamiltonian as
1/2 x1 squared plus u squared--
and here, I'm omitting a
dependency on time just to save
some ink--
plus the costate times
our dynamics function, p1,
p2 transpose x2 minus x2 plus
u, which we can write as 1/2 x1
squared plus u squared plus
p1 x2 minus p2 x2 plus p2 u.
So this is just our Hamiltonian.
Now, we want to enforce our
third condition, that is,
that u has to be a global
minimizer of the Hamiltonian,
so the new condition that
we just strengthened.
So we basically want to
solve this problem here.
So u star has to be a global
minimizer of the Hamiltonian.
Now, if this is the
Hamiltonian, the only terms
that depend on u's
are these two here.
And so this problem essentially
boils down to minimizing over u
1/2 u squared plus p2 u.
Is the marker strong
enough this week.
Not really?
All right.
Let's try this other one.
I love the variance of the--
yes.
All right.
But can you read this one here?
Anybody that cannot read it?
All right.
So notice that this is
a quadratic function.
So in order to minimize
it, we can just
set the gradient
of this equal to 0.
So we can just set the gradient
with respect to u of this thing
here, so 1/2 u squared
plus p2 u equal to 0,
which essentially means that u
plus p2 has to be equal to 0.
And so u star is
equal to minus p2.
So now to answer
to your question,
you see here we solved
an optimization problem.
The output of this
optimization problem
is still expressing u as a
function of only p in this case.
But in general, it could
be a function of x and p.
Now, we have to analyze-- so
we have-- u has some bounds.
So we have some bounds
on the values of u.
And so we need to
basically look at
different case-by-case studies.
So specifically, we will
be looking at three cases
where our bounds are that u has
to be between minus 1 and 1.
And so we'll be
looking at the case
where this global
minimizer, minus p2,
is smaller than negative 1.
We'll be looking at minus p2
being between minus 1 and 1
or the fact that minus
p2 is greater than 1.
We'll be looking at
these three cases,
because ideally, the optimal
control will be negative p2,
but there are some bounds on
u that we have to respect.
Visually, if you want to have
a sense of what is happening,
this is a quadratic function, so
something that looks like this.
The minimum is at negative p2.
And now we'll be analyzing
different cases depending
on where minus p2 falls.
So the most obvious one is
if minus p2 is feasible--
so it falls between
negative 1 and 1, so, say,
something like this--
then the optimal u
would just be minus p2.
Now, say that negative p2
is smaller than minus 1.
So we are in a situation
where this is negative.
Say that 1, 1 is here.
What would be the
optimum in this case,
the optimal u in this case?
So this is the function
we want to minimize,
which is our Hamiltonian.
We can only choose
within minus 1 and 1.
So in this case, where
would the minimum be?
Yes.
It's minus 1.
Yeah, exactly.
So in this case, the
minimum would be minus 1.
And you can imagine
a similar argument
if negative p2 is
greater than 1.
So the interval now sits
on the left of negative p2.
And the minimum here would be 1.
So essentially,
now we have solved
the third and
strengthened condition.
So we found the global
minimum of the Hamiltonian
with respect to u.
And now we basically
have what we
need because now we
have an expression of u
as a function of x and p.
In this case, only
the costates p,
which we can substitute in the
differential equations above,
feed them into a solver
and get the solution out.
Interestingly enough--
and this is, I think,
one of the strong points
of indirect methods
is that regardless
of the solution,
so what the exact control
is, we have basically
pinpointed the structure of
how our control looks like.
So now, let's plot our
control u as a function of p2.
Well, we have now is
that our control in
between minus 1 and 1.
So if p2 is between
minus 1 and 1,
it will basically look
something like this.
On the other hand, when
it is below negative 1,
it will be saturating at 1.
And when it is above 1, it
will be saturating at minus 1.
So our control
profile is essentially
linear and saturating
after some point.
Now, of course, in
the moment where
we didn't have those
bounds, our optimal control
would just be the linear point.
Any questions on this?
Yeah.
I understand this is the third
condition of the Pontryagin's
minimum principle.
What about the other two?
Yes, it's a good question.
So basically, now
here, we express u
as a function of x and p.
The mechanics of this go that
then we take this expression.
We substitute it in the other
two differential equation
conditions.
And we get some
differential equations,
which we then solve either
analytically as we did last week
or as we will see today
through numerical solvers.
So this is the best one.
Yes.
So here, we basically
stopped halfway there.
So we just derived
the profile of u.
So it's just the
strengthened condition.
If you had to go
all the way through,
you would substitute this in
the other differential equation
then solve those
differential equations.
Here, we just stopped here.
But it's already said that
already at this point,
we can basically inspect the
structure of our control,
because whenever we will solve
those differential equations,
we will get x's and p's.
And those x's and
p's-- in this case,
only p will allow us to pinpoint
our actual control, which,
regardless of the value of p,
will look like something like
this.
How do we use the
tf [INAUDIBLE]?
Those will be used to
pinpoint the-- those
will be boundary
conditions, which
we use to pinpoint the
constants of integration
in our differential equations.
Yes.
So for the example graph
that you drew there
that explained how you found
conditions, what would--
is the x-axis-- what axis
represents what-- which one is u
and which one-- or
[INAUDIBLE] misunderstanding.
Yeah, so this would
be u, and this
would be the Hamiltonian
as a function of u.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
Any other questions on this?
We will see three more examples.
So now we'll go through
a few of these cases.
And so indeed-- so
exactly what we get
is this control,
so essentially what
we derived here on the
slide-- on the whiteboard.
As a caveat, Pontryagin
and colleagues
derived some additional
necessary conditions
depending on the exact
structure of the problem.
These are not too
relevant for us
for the purposes of
this class, but I just
wanted to mention that there
are some additional optimality
conditions that were derived.
Specifically, if the
final time is fixed
and the Hamiltonian does not
depend explicitly on time,
then the optimality condition
is that the Hamiltonian-- it
has to be constant for all
times between t0 and tf.
And on the other hand, if the
final time and the Hamiltonian
is free and Hamiltonian does
not depend explicitly on time,
then the Hamiltonian
has to be equal to 0
for all times between t0 and tf.
Now, again, do not read
too much into this.
This is just-- I wanted
to use this as an example
to mention that there have been
developed additional optimality
conditions which, at
the end of the day,
are useful to pinpoint
even further the structure
of your solution.
So there are a number
of optimality conditions
which have been
developed, and these
are additional ones compared to
the ones that we showed before.
And if your problem falls
within these buckets, then
the more optimality conditions
you have, the better,
because you can
characterize even
further what your optimal
solution looks like.
So what we'll be doing
now is that we'll
be looking at three archetypes
essentially of optimal control
problems.
Specifically, we'll be looking
at minimum time problems,
so get to your goal
as fast as possible.
We'll be looking at minimum
fuel problems, where
the costs will be to
minimize the absolute value
of the control effort.
Again, you could see this as
the analog of minimizing thrusts
if you're looking at
aerospace applications.
And then we'll be looking
at minimum energy problems.
And so starting from
minimum time problems,
we'll be looking at the
case where indeed we have
some bounds on the controls.
So the control u has to be
between some lower bound, Mi
minus and some
upper bound Mi plus.
And we want to drive a
control affine system.
So for these examples,
we will always
be assuming the exact
same system, which
is a control affine system,
in the sense that it linearly
depends on the control ut.
But this may potentially depend
nonlinearly on the state x.
And this is because the a and
b might be nonlinear in x.
But this still-- so it is
fairly general, dynamical system
and formulation, but it does
simplify slightly things
because it is linear
in the controls.
And, again, the purpose
of minimum time problems
is to get to a goal
as fast as possible.
In this case, we want to start
from an arbitrary state x0,
and we want to reach the origin.
And the way we encode
this minimum time--
the minimization of time
in terms of a functional
is that we want to
minimize j, which
is just the integral
between t0 and tf of 1.
So we're just summing
time essentially.
Yes.
What does i represent here?
Is it a time index?
Or is it a different
possible admissible controls?
We are assuming that u here
could be a multivariate.
And so we have M
control variables.
Yeah.
Oh.
And then would you
know if there's
a comparison [INAUDIBLE]?
Yes.
So imagine maybe
you can accelerate
in different directions.
And for each of
those dimensions,
you have some limits.
So let's apply what we
know to solve this problem.
So as usual, we want to start
from defining the Hamiltonian.
So the Hamiltonian for us
entails the state cost g,
which for us is just 1 plus the
costates times our dynamics.
And so in this case, it will
be p transpose a plus b.
Now, just as a
notation, here, we
will express b, the matrix b,
as in terms of its columns.
So we can just rewrite b in this
way, which essentially means
that this is equal to 1 plus p
transpose a plus the sum that
goes from i to m of bi, ui.
And this is because
then this product
here essentially becomes
the linear combination
of its columns, essentially.
And we can rewrite this
as 1 plus p transpose
a plus the summation
that goes from 1 to m
of p transpose bi, ui.
So here, we just
wrote our Hamiltonian.
Now, as we did before,
we want to start
from the third-order optimality
conditions, which in this case
and according to the
Pontryagin's minimum principle,
it means that we
want to find u, that
is, the global minimizer
of the Hamiltonian.
So, as usual, u star
will be the minimum
with respect to u
of the Hamiltonian,
which, again, out of
these three terms,
only the last one depends on u.
And so this essentially means
that we want to minimize u
of this summation within
1m of that term over there,
so p transpose bi, ui.
Now, the controls are
something that we pick.
And these are independent
according to our problem
formulation across m.
And so minimizing the
summation is essentially
equivalent to minimizing
the individual submission
terms for all i's
that go from 1 to m.
And so this basically
maps to minimizing over
ui of p transpose bi, ui for
all i's that goes from 1 to m.
Now, does this make sense?
Yes.
Now, how do we minimize this?
So, again, I think it's good
to consider different cases.
So specifically, our
optimal control u star
will depend on whether p
transpose bi is positive
or whether p transpose
bi is negative.
So if p transpose
bi is positive,
what is the minimizer
u in this case?
So we want to minimize this term
over here as a function of u.
This will depend on what
this term in front of u is.
And so if this term is positive
and u has to be between Mi minus
and Mi plus, how would
you pick u in this case?
Negative x's.
Yeah, correct, exactly.
So Mi And, of course, by
mirroring, in case p transpose
bi is negative, what is u here?
It will be the upper
bound, so Mi plus.
Now, are we missing
something here?
0.
Yeah, exactly.
And the point here is
that for p transpose
bi, for optimal controls
for which p transpose bi is
optimal triplets, so optimal
x, u, and p, for which
p transpose bi's is equal to 0,
the optimality conditions do not
give us any characterization
of any information about what
the optimal control looks like.
This is a condition that is
referred to as singular arcs
or singular conditions,
which essentially says
that the optimality conditions
for some characteristics
of our triplet do not
give us any information
about the optimal control u.
Now, for the purposes
of this class,
we won't be dealing
with singular arcs,
and so this is not a problem
that should bother you too much.
But I just wanted to
use this example as--
indeed an example
of the problems
that could emerge,
whereby in this case,
there could be the situation
where my optimal is actually
lies in a situation where
for some portion of my time,
p transpose bi is equal to 0.
And so I would not know how
to characterize my controls.
Now, there could be some
much more sophisticated math
in order to pinpoint the
behavior of my control
in this case.
It is easier for linear systems.
It becomes much a
problem-depending solution
in the moment where you're
looking at nonlinear systems.
But I think it's just
important for you
to know that there
might be situations
where these problems emerge.
And in a way, this is actually
where most of the brainpower,
when you try to use
indirect methods goes into,
is tackling these
ill-conditioned situations.
For us, assuming
that the optimal--
for our optimal
control problem--
so the optimal
triplet x, p, and u
does not fall into the
singular conditions--
we basically have
determined that our control
has this form
here, which is also
known as a bang-bang control.
And this is because
essentially, the control
has a profile that either
accelerates at max velocity
or breaks at its maximum.
And if you think about what
we were doing here, that is,
minimizing final
time, it makes sense.
So we have some linear system
or a control affine system.
We want to minimize time.
And so we're not messing around.
We either go full throttle, or
we break at our maximum speed.
Yes.
So [INAUDIBLE] is equal to 0.
Does that not necessarily
mean that it's
uncontrollable at that state?
It means that the
optimality conditions do not
give us a characterization of
how the control looks like.
So remember, all of these
are optimality conditions
that allow us to pinpoint
candidates for optimality.
And so this means that
in those situations,
these optimality conditions
do not give us information
on what an optimal looks like.
Yes.
What is singular arcs?
What types of problems
these are unique to?
They're not unique
to specific problems,
but singular arc or
singular condition
refers to those situations for
which the optimality conditions
are not able to characterize
the control essentially.
It's not new to the
application of the Pontryagin's
minimum principle?
Yes, yes.
So if you're applying the
Pontryagin's minimum principle,
that is, the optimality
conditions for optimal control
problems, you might end up in
situations like these where we--
at face value, we don't
have enough information
to characterize what
the control looks like.
Sorry.
You said this already,
but I'm just confused.
Did you get that the controller
is a bang-bang controller
from minimizing the Hamiltonian,
or the problem gave you
that this is a
bang-bang controller?
So, again, here, I think the
mental mindset you should be in
is that we are being
extremely methodical.
So we have an optimal
control problem,
and we follow the recipe.
So the recipe entails
defining the Hamiltonian
and then enforcing the
optimality conditions.
The way we mechanically
go through the optimality
conditions is by starting
from the third one, which
is the, in this case, finding
use the globally minimize
the Hamiltonian, which
leads us to this.
If we were to continue, we would
then take this and substitute it
in the differential equations.
We would then solve those
differential equations
and get the full thing.
Here, we're, again,
stopping before the solution
of the differential equations,
that is, we only get
the global minimum
of the Hamiltonian.
And this already
gives us the profile
of our control signal,
which, in this case,
is bang-bang, because we already
know that we will basically
be at the maximum control on
the boundaries of our control
at all times essentially,
removing the singular arc
discussion.
Yeah.
And so essentially,
we showed what
to do when p transpose
b is different from 0.
It is not obvious what we
do in the equal to 0 case.
And we discussed this--
we refer to these situations are
singular conditions or singular
arcs.
And I do-- if you're
interested in learning more,
the textbook from Kurt we
were referring to last week
is indeed a good
reference for this
because it has some discussions.
OK, so now we move towards a
second archetype optimal control
problem, which is minimum fuel.
So in this case, we
have the same boundary--
bounds on the controls.
We have the exact same
control affine system.
But now we are changing
the cost, whereby we
start from an arbitrary x of 0.
We want to reach the
origin in a fixed time.
So now, time is fixed.
It's not a variable
we're optimizing over.
And we want to reach the origin
by minimizing the absolute value
of the control.
And these types
of problems where
minimizing absolute
values of the controls
are usually referred to
as minimum fuel problems.
So, again, let's follow
the usual procedure.
So we define the Hamiltonian
which, in this case,
g for us is the sum
from 1 to m of ci times
the absolute value of ui
plus p transpose a plus
the sum that goes from 1
to m of p transpose bi, ui.
Here, I skipped a
couple of steps,
but this is exactly-- because
the steps are exactly the same
as the ones we did before.
So we express b as in form--
in terms of the columns.
And then that
product essentially
becomes the linear combination
of the columns of b.
Is it clear how we got to-- how
we define the Hamiltonian here?
So now, we want to enforce
our optimality condition such
that the u has to be a
minimizer of the Hamiltonian.
And, again, in this case, the
only terms that depend on u
are the first and the third.
And so this boils down to
taking the minimum over u
of the sum that goes
from 1 to m of ci times
the absolute value of ui
plus p transpose bi, ui.
Now, again, the u's are--
the dimensions of
u are independent.
And so we can do
exactly the same trick
that minimizing the summation
is equal and equivalent
to minimizing the
individual summation
term for all i's from 1 to n.
And so this means that it's
equal to minimizing over ui's
of ci times the absolute value
of ui plus p transpose bi, ui.
And this is for all
i's from 1 to m.
So now, let's write this
term slightly more nicely.
So this is equal to ci plus
p transpose bi times ui
if ui is greater or
equal than 0 and is
equal to negative ci
plus P transpose bi,
ui if ui is less
than or equal than 0.
And so we want to
minimize this object.
And, again, we have to go
in a case-by-case analysis.
So if p transpose bi is
greater than ci, what happens
is that this term is positive.
And so what u would I pick here
if I want to minimize this term?
[INAUDIBLE]
Sorry.
I think I heard a 0.
Yes, which is correct.
Did I hear you mean
something else or--
no.
So indeed, it is 0.
And so indeed-- so in the case
where p transpose bi is greater
than or equal to c than--
greater than ci, this
is greater than 0,
which means that, in this case,
I would pick ui equals to 0.
If we're still in that case,
then this other condition
would also be positive.
So this term here
is also positive.
And so here, the ui that I
would pick would be Mi minus.
And so in between these two
cases then for this case
here, ui star would
be equal to MI minus.
Now we do another case, that
is, the case where p transpose
bi is between 0 and ci.
If this is the case,
this is still positive.
So here, I would also
pick ui equals 0.
If b transpose bi
is between 0 and ci,
this term here is negative.
And so the ui that
I would have to pick
would also be 0 to minimize.
And so essentially, in this
case, u star i is equal to 0.
Now, just by
mirroring, I-- yeah,
we would go through the other
two remaining cases, which
essentially are that p transpose
bi are between negative ci and 0
and the fact that p transpose
bi is smaller than negative ci.
So these would be
the other two cases.
And here, we would get
that ui star is equal to 0
and that ui star
is equal Mi plus.
This is just by mirroring.
And so, again, we
reached the point
where we have expressed u from
the third of our boundary--
from our necessary
optimality conditions.
And we see that we are--
again, we are assuming we're not
in the singular arc conditions.
So we are ignoring the equal
cases of these examples here.
But we have, again,
pinpointed the structure
of our control profile.
And this is the one that you
can see here on the slide
where ui, depending on the
value of p transpose bi,
is essentially either at
its minimum value or 0
or at its maximum value.
And this is known as
bang-off-bang control.
And if you think about
what we're doing here,
it is quite intuitive, again,
because this essentially
describes control
profiles where I
want to get as quickly
as possible into a state
where I'm essentially
coasting through my dynamics,
where I can do
nothing essentially,
and then maybe only at the end
do another impulsive control.
And this aligns with the
objective of minimizing fuel.
Any questions on this example?
I think here, it's easy to
get lost in the technicalities
of solving this minimization.
But I hope that at a high
level, what we're doing
is starting to become clear,
because we're essentially
repeating ourselves over and
over where we are enforcing
our optimality conditions.
By defining the Hamiltonian,
optimizing the Hamiltonian
with respect to u, this
gives us a control profile,
which in order to solve
the problem fully,
we would have to then do
the appropriate substitution
and solve the
differential equations.
But this already gives us a
way to analyze the structure
of our control profile.
Yes.
Yeah.
Sorry.
So when you were
doing the ci plus pt,
bi that is just you
getting that derivative
and seeing-- that just
gave me a derivative
based on whatever the
absolute value is.
And then you were looking at
the different options of pt,
bi greater than ci.
I'm a little bit
confused how then you
got that they are
for the minimum based
on pt, bi greater than ci,
because if pti is bigger,
then that's not just
a positive values.
And then the [INAUDIBLE]
of ui is just 0.
And then so why is it now
that the minimum [INAUDIBLE]?
You're talking about this
case here, these cases?
Yeah.
So here, remember that our
function we're optimizing
is this one here.
So it's a function where
we have an absolute value.
Yes.
And so we rewrote it
according to these two cases.
Yes.
Now, we are doing the
case where p transpose
bi is greater than ci.
And we want to find the minimum
across both of these values.
So if p transpose bi is greater
than ci, this is positive.
And in the case where ui
has to be greater than 0,
the minimum would
be ui equals 0.
In this other case,
this is positive.
ui has to be less than 0, and so
the minimum would be Mi minus.
The minimum between the two of
them is when ui is Mi minus.
All right.
Thank you.
Would this have
the singular arcs
where obviously still the
0 case but also when they
equal to ci and negative ci?
Yes, indeed.
Here, we are assuming that
our optimal control does not
fall into these conditions.
Yeah.
Conceptually, I'm wondering, in
the bang-off-bang bang control
sequence, is there
something in those terms
that also weighs total time?
Or is it purely just
minimizing fuel?
If you look at the objective
that we were doing,
we didn't have an explicit
minimization over time,
but time was fixed.
Yeah.
So the third case of the
minimum energy problem--
I would just go through
this quite quickly
because it's exactly
the same case as the one
that we did on our parabola
and the negative p2
that we did just after
the definition of the PMP.
So I would go through
this quite quickly.
Again, here, the cases
that we're minimizing--
R squared cost functional.
And we would be doing the
exact same steps where
we define the Hamiltonian.
This Hamiltonian,
because of the-- we
are assuming that R is
positive definite and diagonal.
And so because of this,
everything nicely decouples.
And so we get the same situation
where minimizing this summation
terms is equal to minimizing
an individual term
of the summation.
And so since this
is quadratic, we
set the derivative
of this equal to 0.
And we will get this optimal
control, which is exactly
the analog of the negative p2.
So this is why I'm coasting
through this because this
is exactly the same.
And so we would get
our saturating control,
which is the case we were
looking at the beginning.
So we had our control saturating
when it's out of bounds, linear,
and then saturating again.
Yes.
So we know to pick
R as a diagonal.
If that makes the
calculation straightforward,
why is that applicable?
I mean, R-- if you
think about it,
it's a term we pick because we
are defining the costs that we
want to optimize.
And so usually, it's good to
express diagonal cost matrices
because it makes things easier.
But we could also pick an
R that is not diagonal.
Yeah.
So I want to--
so I have only 10 minutes
left, so I'll skip over this
and finish it next time.
But I want to give you a
hint on computational methods
and show you how to solve
these problems in practice.
And so basically,
until now, what we did
is that we used our
optimality conditions
to derive our systems of
differential equations
and our minimization
over u condition.
And then we always stopped
at the-- either we solve them
analytically as we did
last week, or here,
we stopped at expressing u
as a function of x and p's.
And then we said that
here, we would substitute
these back in our
differential equations,
and we would solve them
through numerical solvers.
And at a high level,
numerical techniques
to solve two-point
boundary value problems
divide themselves in between
indirect shooting methods
and collocation methods.
Now, we won't go
into the details
of how these models,
these techniques
solve two-point
boundary value problems.
But at a high level, you
should see a shooting method
as basically a method
that approximates
a two-point boundary value
problem as an initial value
problem where I take a guess
of what the initial value is.
I propagate my system forward.
I see my error with respect
to the final condition.
I will get a residual.
And then I update my
guesses iteratively.
In direct collocation
methods, on the other hand,
approximate the system dynamics
through basis functions,
for example, polynomials.
And they enforce the dynamics
and the boundary conditions
at some specific points, which
are called collocation points.
And so these are-- again,
don't read too much into this,
but this is just--
if you want to open the box
of how these numerical solvers
typically operate,
they're either
implementing a shooting method
or a collocation method.
And we will be
looking at our example
that it also came
up earlier today,
where we are
essentially optimizing
the particle on a line.
And we solved this
analytically, where we basically
derived the value of tf.
But before getting there, I
wanted to just briefly introduce
in an abstract example how these
numerical solvers look like.
And specifically, we'll be using
the solve_bvp method in SciPy,
where, at a high level,
the solve_bvp essentially
takes in a fun argument, which
represents the right-hand side
of our dynamics.
BC, which represents
the boundary conditions,
expressed as the residuals
of the boundary conditions.
So it has to be
something equal to 0.
t, which is like a mesh
of time, meaning we
are discretizing time according
to some discrete bins.
And so this will be just a
sequence of discretization time
steps, which is just a
series of increasing numbers.
z will be our
aggregated up variable.
Essentially here, we will have
all our states and costates
stacked together.
And so to see this
in practice, let's
look at a simple examples like
the one here on the slide.
So, again, as I said, what
these solvers usually take
is this solve_bvp
where we need to define
first of all the function, so
our differential equations.
And in the example
that we're looking at,
we have this system
where we have
z1 dot equals z2
and z2 dot equals
negative absolute value of z1.
And so here, we're
just basically stacking
those dynamics.
So we have-- remember that in
Python, counting starts from 0.
So we basically have that
z1 dot is equal to z2.
So here, we're just saying z2.
And then we have z2 dot equals
negative absolute value of z1.
And so we have negative
absolute value of z1.
Now we need to enforce our
boundary conditions, which
are that z1 at time 0 is
equal to 0 and z1 at time 4
is equal to negative 2.
And so what we have here-- so
za is intended for the boundary
conditions at the initial time.
And so we have za0 equal
to 0, which is essentially
this term over here.
And then we have
z1 4 plus 2 equals
0, because we have to express
them in the residual form, which
is what we have here.
Now, we construct the t_mesh,
which essentially is, again,
just a number which informs what
is our discretization of time,
in this case, from 0 to 4.
And we assume we have
five bins between 0 and 4.
And z_guess is just
an initial guess
of our variables at those times.
So what happens if
we just run this
is that basically, we get that
the differential equations are
solved.
So this is the plot of
z1 and z2 over time.
So first of all, it
goes from 0 to 4.
And note that z1 starts at
0, which was our boundary
condition here.
And it ends at negative 2, which
was our final time boundary
condition.
And then note that--
so z2 is defined as the
time derivative of z1.
And so when z2 is
positive, z1 grows.
When z2 is negative,
z1 also decreases.
So this is just a
visual inspection
that we did indeed solve
these differential equations.
Yeah, I think I'll take
some questions now,
and then I'll wrap
this up next time.
Yes.
Is z2 completely
[INAUDIBLE] because you
take the z2 dot equals negative
z1 and the [INAUDIBLE].
So do you [INAUDIBLE]?
In this case, z2
has to basically--
is something that
always decreases,
because the time
derivative of z2
is negative and absolute value.
And so if you also
inspect this visually,
this is what is happening.
But if you're talking about
other specific constraints
on z2, in this case,
we don't have any.
So it can start and
end at any values?
Mm-hmm.
All right.
So see you on
Wednesday while we'll
be wrapping this
computational methods.
And then we'll introduce
direct methods.
Thank you.